[Musica]
ma la tripla
[Applauso]
nato
[Musica]
toni che smith
firma
[Musica]
nave
può bastare adesso faccio una pausa
quante volte ci troviamo a dire faccio
una pausa ho bisogno di una pausa magari
è una pausa caffè rapidissima oppure è
una pausa di riflessione in un rapporto
o una pausa per andare a fare la pipì o
una pausa studio tra un esame e l'altro
no molti studenti universitari prendono
una pausa studio che spesso si traduce
in più anni fuori corso
la pausa è fondamentale pensate la pausa
in un discorso la propria in un monologo
teatrale in una frase musicale sono
quelle che conosco meglio le sento più
congeniali probabilmente anche voi state
facendo una pausa per vedere questo
video
la pausa è essenziale perché tutto possa
poi riprendere a scorrere
tranquillamente o freneticamente se
volete perché la velocità di scorrimento
delle proprie vite
è una cosa che scegliamo noi e in parte
la pausa importante persino in uno
spazio fisico di un muro
immaginate una parete bianca nel vostro
salotto una parete che domina la stanza
ed è pronta lì per svolgere la sua
funzione principale che non è come
dicono gli architetti quella di separare
gli ambienti nel migliore dei modi no
come dicono le mogli degli architetti la
parete lì perché ci si mettano dei
quadri o qualsiasi cosa di probabilmente
inutile voi abbiate in causa
ecco la nostra bella parete e li aspetta
il primo quadro finalmente noi lo
attendiamo
ed ecco che succede una cosa molto
strana
lo spazio intorno al quadro quel muro
bianco apparentemente scompare ma è lì
per esaltare quel quadro quindi da un
lato noi non lo vediamo se ci chiedono
cosa vedete noi diremo probabilmente un
bel quadro non una bella parete con
sopra un quadro da un lato sparisce
dall'altro invece è fondamentale quel
bianco e lì poi arriva il secondo quadro
a debita distanza dal primo
anzi ad una distanza che gli amanti
dell'estetica hanno addirittura
definito ogni quadro viene appeso
allineato secondo una linea orizzontale
immaginaria che passa per il centro del
quadro stesso l'altezza dal pavimento
deve essere a 5 ottavi dell'altezza
totale della parete abbastanza precisa
come definizione arriva il terzo quadro
poi magari il quarto quadro e magari una
maschera di terracotta di qualche
artigiano salentino ed ecco che lo
spazio fra i quadri cominciano ad essere
vitale fondamentale perché quella pausa
quella parentesi che c'è fra i due
quadri permette ad ogni singolo quadro
di avere dignità di essere visibile di
essere visto di essere percepito se
paradossalmente noi lentissimo l'intera
parete con tanti quadri anche il miglior
capolavoro del mondo semplicemente
scomparirebbe
ecco cosa serve la pausa ecco qual è la
funzione di una parentesi a dare valore
e spazio a tutto quanto il resto ad
incorniciare
ad accendere i riflettori su qualcosa
che probabilmente non avremmo notato io
penso che questo sia un principio
naturale insito addirittura
nell'universo adesso mi allargo un po
l'universo è composto per il 4 per cento
da stelle pianeti polveri e
cianfrusaglie cosmiche bari e per il
restante 96 per cento di materia oscura
quello che prima si pensava fosse vuoto
ecco nella mia visione forse poco
scientifica troppo poetica dell'universo
per me quella materia oscura e la pausa
fra le stelle è quello che permette alle
stelle di brillare
faccio il musicista intendo proprio il
musicista di professione sono cioè fra
quelle a cui mediamente viene ancora
chiesto quando dico che faccio un
musicista si ma il tuo lavoro vero e io
per un lavoro vero ci sono passato sono
laureata in economia e commercio e
credetemi non c'entra molto con fare poi
il musicista jazz
conosco dall'interno del mondo delle
aziende perché
sono stato key account o meglio creduto
di essere lo forze per un paio di
multinazionali ma sono uno che ha
inseguito il proprio sogno anche se a
dirla tutta in maniera abbastanza
inconsapevole da ragazzino io mi perdevo
ogni volta che andavo ad assistere un
concerto in guardavo il palco amici
immaginavo su accarezzato dalle luci con
la gente che cantava le mie canzoni a
suonare ea cantare quando ero piccolino
i miei vicini suonavano avevo un
dirimpettaio che suonava la chitarra è
quello del piano di sotto che suonava
l'organo io attaccavo l'orecchio per
sentire ogni nota che passava attraverso
il pavimento attraverso la parete
costruendo forse inconsapevolmente
quello che sarei diventato dopo
naturalmente non è filato tutto liscio
perché c'era la scuola che mi impegnava
tanto le mi interessava poco
poi c'era l'università dove ero anche
abbastanza in gamma prendevo anche buoni
voti ma passione 0 e poi una tesi
completamente inventata sicura posso
dirlo
tutti i dati della mia tesi sperimentale
sono stati inventati ma penso che non se
lo stato né il primo né l'ultimo e poi
il percorso classico almeno in italia
dei degli stage formativi non remunerati
qualche lavoretto finalmente il primo
contratto e poi il primo stipendio
quello che io chiamo l'antidolorifico
quello che mi faceva dimenticare che
stavo in realtà soffrendo
vi starete chiedendo che cosa c'entri
tutto questo con la pausa con la
parentesi bene la musica erano mia pausa
per la mia parentesi meravigliosa era il
mio muro bianco su cui ho finalmente
potevo sentirmi libero e fra una pausa e
l'altra sono arrivati addirittura un
matrimonio
villetta a schiera con il prato inglese
da curare tutto quanto voi possiate
immaginare
quindi diciamo che la situazione era
questa svolgimento del tema matrimonio
lavoro prato inglese parentesi la musica
poi senza volerlo è successa una cosa
strana la parentesi ha cominciato ad
allargarsi sempre di più a diventare a
volte anche invadente qualche volta è
diventata qualcosa contro cui lottare
addirittura come l'universo ha
cominciato a prendersi più spazio e la
materia oscura è arrivata al 96 per
cento punto più punto meno capite quanto
importanti possano essere le pause che
valore possano assumere le parentesi
nello nell'esprimere un concetto come
nello svolgimento della propria vita
naturalmente dipende molto da come
quelle pause le si utilizza da come le
parentesi e andiamo a riempire io per
anni ho studiato ho ascoltato la musica
che mi piaceva ho cercato di imparare
ciò che amavo ho cercato di essere una
persona migliore di ciò che ero il
giorno prima non sono stato sempre così
virtuoso molte volte molte delle mie
parti si sono state completamente vuote
come quella volta in cui decisi di
vendere tutte quante le mie chitarre
perché volevo fare il pallavolista ma
forse a pensarci bene anche quelle pause
anche quelle parentesi nella propria
vita
se lette nella maniera giusta hanno un
valore sono importanti per capire in che
direzione non vogliamo andare e quindi
sono dei test per cercare una strada che
magari troviamo più congeniale insomma
come per una parete per i suoi quadri lo
spazio che vivevo fra un accadimento
della vita e l'altro quelle parentesi si
erano trasformate nella vita stessa
quelle pause e oniriche perso fra le
nuvole dei sogni erano diventate il tema
principale aveva invertito le parentesi
con il tema se mi è costato fatica
questa inversione
tantissima tantissima fatica mi è
costata un matrimonio mi è costata una
villetta a schiera
ma almeno adesso il vantaggio di non
avere il prato inglese da curare vivere
le mie parentesi a pieno mi ha permesso
però di rinascere di far combaciare il
dentro e il fuori di me stesso che è né
più né meno quello che io auguro a tutti
in particolare ai miei giovani allievi
ho potuto avere di nuovo una nuova vita
un nuovo matrimonio una nuova casa
questa volta però non mi sono fatto
fregare niente prato inglese
vi lascio con la frase di un grande
poeta francese apollinare di tanto in
tanto e bene fare una pausa nella nostra
ricerca della felicità è semplicemente
essere felice grazie
[Musica]